[ Air horn blowing ]
-Oh!
-[ German accent ] Danke schoen.
Season greetings, Jimmy.
Looks like Kris Kringle
came early,
'cause I have a gift for you --
a dancing game.
Okay, here are the rules,
so pay attention.
Two of you will put on your
noise-canceling headphones.
Then I will play you
a hot track,
and your partners will have to
get you to guess that song
just by acting out the title.
But here's the tricky part.
The whole time, you will be
spinning right 'round
like a record, baby.
-Oh, geez.
-That's right.
-Wow. Don't throw up.
[ Air horn blowing ]
Ja. Those records
will be rotating,
so you won't always
be facing your partner.
Each song is worth 1,000 points.
Let's see who can name
the most bangers, ja?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm sorry in advance.
-Take your positions.
Ana, Rachel, go ahead
and put on your headphones.
Look at the drip on those.
I stan.
Fred, Melissa, you are
giving the clues this round.
Let's start the rotation.
3, 2, 1.
♪♪
-♪ Stop in the name of love ♪
-"Stop! In the Name of Love."
-♪ Before you break my heart ♪
-Yes. That's good.
-♪ Who let the dogs out? ♪
♪ Who, who, who, who, who ♪
♪ Who let the dogs out? ♪
-Uh, "Who Let the Dogs Out."
-That's nice.
-♪ Rockin' around
the Christmas tree ♪
♪ At the Christmas party hop ♪
♪ Mistletoe hung
where you can see ♪
-Uh, "Rockin' Around
the Christmas Tree."
-Yes, very nice.
♪♪
-♪ Biggie, Biggie, Biggie,
can't you see ♪
♪ Sometimes your words
just hypnotize me ♪
♪ And I just love
your flashy ways ♪
-I'm being hypnotized.
Hypnosis.
-♪ Baby shark,
doo doo doo doo doo doo ♪
♪ Baby shark,
-Oh, go, Fred.
-♪ Baby shark ♪
♪ Doo doo doo doo doo doo ♪
-Uh, little rabbit.
-♪ Baby shark ♪
-Oh, God.
-♪ Mommy shark,
doo doo doo doo doo doo ♪
-Quick, five seconds.
-Uh, shark.
-4...
-♪ Doo doo doo doo doo doo ♪
♪ Mommy shark ♪
-...3...
-"Baby Oh Baby."
-...2...
-"Baby Shark," "Baby Shark."
-Yes.
You got it.
[ Air horn blows ]
Oh, that's it.
Wow!
-Good job, Rachel.
-Amazing.
-That was hot.
Let's play one more round,
but this time
you will exchange roles.
Fred, Melissa,
put on those fabulous
noise-canceling headphones.
Ana, Rachel, it's your turn
to slay all day.
-Oh, boy.
-Okay.
Let's start the rotation.
3, 2, 1.
Go!
-♪ It's fun to stay at the ♪
♪ YMCA ♪
♪ It's fun to stay at the ♪
-"YMCA."
-♪ YMCA ♪
-Good job, Fred.
-♪ Ah, push it ♪
♪ Ah, push it ♪
-Uh, "Push It."
-Yes. Nice.
-♪ Firework ♪
♪ Come on,
let your colors burst ♪
-This is a tough one.
-♪ Make 'em go, oh, oh, oh ♪
-Uh, baby -- "Firework."
-♪ You're gonna leave 'em ♪
-Oh, you got it. Wow.
-♪ Workin' at the car wash ♪
♪ Workin' at the car wash,
yeah ♪
-Driving. Drive.
Driving. Window, window.
Uh, window washer.
-"Car Wash."
-Wow, very nice, Melissa.
-♪ That girl is poison ♪
-Wondering.
Wondering.
-Come on. Uh-oh.
"Grandma Got Run Over
by a Reindeer"?
Oh.
-Five seconds.
-What is it?
-I don't know.
-3...
-♪ Poison ♪
-...2...
-Oh.
-Oh, that's it right there.
What a game.
Wow!
-That's real.